there is a new danger looming as this
country struggles to get the coronavirus
under control america's seven day
average has now hit nearly 130 000 new
covid cases and over the last week we
averaged more than a hundred thousand
people in the hospital in the hospital
nearly all of those people unvaccinated
now health experts are warning about a
potential kind of double pandemic a twin
endemic during flu season this fall as
kids go back to school especially in
areas without mask mandates cbs news
medical contributor dr david agus joins
us now with more on this dr aegis good
morning to you simple question how
should we prepare for this so-called
twindemk
yeah tony we hope it doesn't happen but
in the average year 30 to 60 000 deaths
from the influenza or the flu
300 to 600 000 hospitalizations and 10
to 15 million doctors visits so you
couple that with covet 19 and it can
really strain the system and then
there's a fact we don't know what
happens when you get both is it a double
whammy and getting people more sick so
we certainly are afraid last year pretty
wimpy flu season
mainly because of the precautions we
took to kova 19 which also prevent the
flu this year as precautions are going
down we're getting worried
is it safe to get a flu shot and a
covered shot in the same time
period
um yeah so
well i guess i should say the real
answer is we don't necessarily know and
so the studies are ongoing now giving a
flu shot together with the copa 19
vaccine and they probably are safe that
being said i would suggest if you're
going to get them to probably separate
them from a week or two if you can if
logistically it's too hard it's probably
okay what you're worried about is the
side effects of both of them creating a
little bit more you know the combination
and we just don't know the answer there
so i'd rather people separate if they
could yeah well you scared me a little
bit david when uh tony said is it safe
to get them both and you went yeah
and then like we don't know then you
also said we don't know which i think is
is something that we should all take
into account when should we get the flu
shot
um i have to realize that i am speaking
to gail king at the moment about a shot
in the arm
[Laughter]
you know i was very resistant to the flu
vac flu shot but i got it i got it and
you don't have to tell me twice about
the cobit you don't have to tell me
twice about that covert vaccine i can't
wait to get a boost we all need
we all need the flu shot this year and
it should be probably toward the end of
september you know the flu shot lasts
about six months of immunity and flu
season is normally kind of october to
potentially may so if we can delay it
and get it the end of september
beginning of october i think that's the
optimal timing even though they're
available now
dr igus are people talking about a combo
flu covered shot
yeah it's in development and you know
probably be around for next season if
it's needed you know a flu shot and the
covenant and we'll see if it's safe
because obviously one injection instead
of two
is a lot easier in everybody we do it in
children we combine vaccines together
and they work together we're waiting to
see what the data are with these two
vaccines
uh the cdc
uh i was going to ask you this question
about this so the cdc is advising
against giving people who are not
immunocompromised so they have a strong
immune system against giving them a
booster shot do you agree with that
no um you know even today you saw the
world health organization come back and
before they had said you know you have
to give vaccines to the whole world
before you give a booster and now they
said we realize that a booster shot is
saving lives and protecting vulnerable
people so
we need to give boosters out to the
united states to get immunity to a level
to protect from the variants because
what we're seeing is slight decreases in
immunity every month after you're
vaccinated and so the further url the
more of a decrease in immunity so i
think we're all going to get booster
shots to really give us four to ten fold
increase in immunity and protect us from
the delta variant and any new ones that
are coming it's so tough to know what to
do david when the cdc says one thing and
doctors on the other side say say
something else it's confusing to us i
agree with you the messaging is off yeah
yeah well my recommendation was
confusing to me yeah
go go to go to your local convenience
store make it a combo get your shot and
pick up a bag of chips while you're
there okay all right dr agus thank you
very much